To summarize the correlation coefficient, which you're just about to learn about,
is a value between -1 and 1, tells us how related or correlated two variables are
and both 1 and -1 stand for perfectly linear data.
In the case of +1, we know that this line increases in x and y simultaneously
whereas for -1, we have the inverse effect.
Let's compute r--my favorite way to compute it is very similar
to the way we computed b in linear regression.
It looks like the sum of all data points and takes the product of (xi-x-bar)
and multiplies for each data point this with (yi - y-bar) and then, we have to normalize.
This could be any value. It isn't between ±1.
We normalize by a √(x-x-bar)² sum of all i's times the same expression for y.
Now this looks a little bit wild, and this is probably the worst formula
you've encountered in this class in terms of complexity but once you dived in,
you'll realize this is really related to a lot of stuff you've seen before such as variances and similar.
This is the quintessential term that occurs in the variance calculation of x.
All that's missing is the normalizer.
Same over here, this is the variance of y--this thing is the normalizer.
We take the product of the variance of x and the variance of y  modally with the normalizers
and we get something quadratic even in variance space.
This over here is kind of a mixed variance. This is often called the covariance.
But notice that there is also a normalizer in this thing over here.
In fact, the missing normalizers on top and bottom of this bar
can't see each other out; hence, I just omitted them.
But this one is just like the variance calculation but it mixes x's and y's whereas these are x² and y².
This is called often covariance if you've normalized, because
it is the variance calculation of a two co-occuring variables.
These are the variances.
So what this really tells you is kind of the ratio how much these two things co-evolve,
how much the errors correspond versus normalized by the multitudes of errors individually
and whether the ratio becomes 1, we have a perfect correlation.
When the ratio becomes 0, then the numerator is 0 which means our errors cancel each other out.
That is very different for x and for y under any linear model.
So this complicated formula is what's called the correlation coefficient r. So let's try this out.